[Musik]
die ecotel de lausanne gehört zu den
renommiertesten handels schulen für die
hotelindustrie 2800 studenten aus über
110 nationen streben an der l nach
exzellenz können uns selbstbewusstsein
wir begleiten drei studenten im
vorbereitungsjahr und zwei am ende ihres
studiums
[Musik]
alexander 18 jahre alt mit seiner matura
in der tasche geht er in das
vorbereitungsjahr immer bitte ist 21 sie
wurde in der genferseeregion geboren und
beginnt ja studium an dieser
internationalen schule genau wie alex
hat ja 19 jahre alt der sohn eines
hoteliers geht mit selbstvertrauen ins
erste semester annina von falkenstein
mit 21 beginnt sie ihr vorletztes
studienjahr
die junge bärin strebt nach nichts
weniger als exzellenz auf rebecca 27
startet sein letztes semester der
energetische afri möchte selbstständiger
unternehmer werden
[Musik]
letztes mal in der hotelfachschule
alexandre zeigt großes selbstvertrauen
als ob das erste semester für den sohn
eines hoteliers nur eine formalität wäre
im herbst gehen wir an die
europameisterschaft in rumänien wo ich
werde möglicherweise ein zwei tage nicht
hier sein können ein wichtiges jahren
aber ich bin bereit
immer hat auch aus eigener tasche
bezahlt und die ehl zu absolvieren
sie gibt alles für den start in das
vorbereitungsjahr und wenn sie jemals
die werte des wirklichen lebens
vergessen hat erinnert sie ihr vater
daran
ich vertraue meiner tochter dass sie
kritisch bleibt gegenüber dieser wir
sind die besten einstellungen trotz
seines jungen alters ist alex bereit
sich an strenge formen anzupassen
unter dem ironischen blick seiner mutter
einer stylistin probiert er seine erste
arbeitskleidung an
[Musik]
es ist aufregend aber auch ein wenig
unheimlich ein abenteuer
annina beginnt ihr vorletztes semester
mit der ernsthaftigkeit die sie
auszeichnet über den lehrplan hinaus
multipliziert sie ihre aktivitäten an
der schule freizeit ist nicht ihre
priorität und so präsentiert sie als
botschafterin die ehl in paris für die
vier jahre kostet es 155.000 schweizer
franken aufnehmen beendet seine laufbahn
an der ehl
er sprudelt vor ideen aber der
schwerpunkt liegt auf der gruppen
diplomprüfung der im studenten business
project sbp wir erfahren gleich worum es
geht
es ist mein letztes projekt das ist
aufregend
ok guten morgen gleich zu beginn
zeitlich funktioniert es hier gar nicht
um 7.25 sollte erscheinen und um 37
sollte alle bereit sein
jetzt haben wir schon fünf minuten
verloren wie viele seiten 16 5 minuten
mal 16 gibt mehr als zwei stunden also
bitte pünktlich erscheinen und euch dann
fünf bis zehn minuten vorzubereiten
das wird kein chef in einem unternehmen
tolerieren habt ihr verstanden bei dhl
wird jeder workshop bewertet und alles
zählt und das verhalten des schülers
es macht die hälfte der note aus mehr
als 15 minuten verspätung ein punkt -
eine berechtigte abwesenheit selbst bei
krankheit ein punkt -
[Musik]
alex wird eingeführt in die freuden der
raumpflege haben sie zweimal geklopft ja
nein nicht zweimal so alles gut
duschkopf lavabo wasserhahn du schwand
um ist kann ich das kurz hier lassen
legen sie es auf den rand oder wenn sie
platz haben oben auf den schrank wenn
der haare sind wir für sie in den abfall
haare alles so schmutzig hier heute ist
der erste tag es gibt leute die noch nie
so etwas gemacht haben
das weiß man nie wenn man eine gruppe
hat es gibt einige die erfahrung von
zuhause haben und schnell sind und
andere die noch nie geputzt haben dann
wird es sehr kompliziert weil sie viel
zeit brauchen und wirklich keine ahnung
habe in den ersten sechs monaten
erfahren die neuen studenten alle
praktischen aspekte der hotellerie welt
von der reinigung der campus zimmer bis
zum service vom spieltisch bis zum
gourmetrestaurant ich weiß dass man es
genau machen muss es wäre einfacher wenn
das ganze amüsanter wäre ist es nicht
amüsant genug
nein nicht wirklich es gibt besseres in
welchem sinn es geht ja nicht nur um
spaß
ja sie haben recht das ist ja eine
arbeit sie sehen wie anstrengend dieser
beruf ist am frühen morgen hat immer die
konditor mütze aufgesetzt
ich liebe das kochen sollte übrigens ich
habe eine frage was ist die beste art
die zitronen torte zuzubereiten
meiner meinung nach ist die beste
methode im wasserbad so mach ich es
und dann gehst du es in die torte du
erhältst so die beste textur danke
könnten sie mir das kurz zeigen
ratschläge von denen sie nur zu hause
profitieren kann
denn in den campus zimmern ist es
verboten zu kochen
es sieht einfach aus ist es aber nicht
die creme muss einwandfrei sein darf
keine klumpen haben so dass sie sauber
aufgetragen werden kann
absoluter meisterschaft perfektion die
ehl zieht die prestigeträchtigsten
dozenten an wie der berühmte dreifarbige
kragen zeigt der kragen ist eine
auszeichnung für einen wettbewerb in
frankreich
ich habe ihn 2015 gewonnen im bereich
patisserie es ist ein wettbewerb der
viel arbeit kostet ich habe zwei jahre
dafür trainiert es ist christlich man
schmeckt den cassis um die maronen es
ist exzellent
ein wahres vergnügen
er hat sich hier gut überlegt wo man
überall putzen muss wo man normalerweise
stattfindet haben sie an die tischbeine
gedacht alex verzeihung ja vergessen sie
die tischbeine nicht staubwischen
flecken reinigen das ist körperliche
arbeit alex erlebt dass täglich acht
stunden fast wie ein echter profi
an diesem morgen muss mst macht 100
stück süßgebäck herstellen in der
produktion ist keine verzögerung erlaubt
die mittagspause duldet keine verspätung
das ist der schokoladen cromwell man
muss darauf achten dass er immer
knusprig ist mit kokosnuss butter
kakaobutter oh mein gott ich habe alles
voll gemacht
ich fühle hier noch schokolade hinzu
[Musik]
alexandra stürzt sich auf das gesunde
essen er bietet den service in der
sektion wellness an die glutenfreie
pasta alle vongole anbietet
wie heißen sie alexandra freue mich ich
zeige ihnen heute ein erstes beispiel
für meinen kollegen der eine portion
essen wird wir werden zusammenarbeiten
perfekt schalotten und knoblauch
den habe ich heute morgen zubereitet
wenn es zu heiß ist drehst du etwas
runter dann die muscheln rang 14 pro
portion
hier sind noch gewürze mittag speisen
fast 2000 studenten und mitarbeiter vor
ort sie haben maximal 45 minuten pause
für alexander steht effizienz auf der
speisekarte
jetzt ist alles klar du musst dir
einiges merken
er erklärt alles schwierig ist sie nicht
ich muss mehr nur die reihenfolge der
zutaten merken
für ihr vorletztes semester genießen
annina und ihre gruppe die freuden des
management vermögensverwaltung
marktanalyse oder reines marketing
theorie umgesetzt in praxis wir
besprechen unser projekt das hotel asset
management es ist ein thema im lehrplan
des fünften bachelor semesters wir
müssen pläne und projekte realisieren
und eine analyse von einem hotel in
berlin machen
es ist eine gute übung um zu wiederholen
was er bereits im unterricht gelernt
haben
es ist auch eine gute vorbereitung für
die prüfung aber es braucht viel zeit
wir sind 300 studierende im semester und
wir machen alle mehr oder weniger
dasselbe projekt das bedeutet dass wir
die besten sein müssen
es ist ein konkurrenzkampf der lehrer
hat gesagt dass diese firma viele neue
angestellte sucht das ist eine weitere
motivation für uns wir werden ja sehen
je mehr die schüler fortschritte in
ihrem studium machen desto härter ist
der wettstreit wie in der berufswelt die
sie erwartet
ein mittagessen unter strenger
überwachung müsse laurent der tempel
wächter des anstands und des guten
aussehens kennt die versammlung kein
detail entgeht ihm
warum tragen sie diese rose das ist kein
dresscode wirklich ist tut mir wirklich
leid das wusste ich nicht
sie müssen sich umziehen ich gebe ihnen
diese karte und beschlagnahme ihren
patch aber ich lebe außerhalb des campus
und habe prüfungen
ich muss sie heute in korrekter kleidung
sehen okay okay ich ziemlich um später
auf dem campus wird der mantel über dem
arm getragen
ein studium bart rasiert
ich studiere hat der muss weg die tages
assistentin von missio lorang macht
straff aufgaben weil sie einen zu kurzen
rock getragen hat ich habe sie gehen
lassen sie hat ihre arbeit gut gemacht
wir waren aktive und proaktiven haben
den schülern die gegen den dresscode
verstoßen eine lektion erteilt null
toleranz ich sehe mich noch weitere wie
heißt du alex schön dich kennenzulernen
service ende für alexandra der sich zeit
nimmt für seine kunden
nebenan tablett der teller ist heiß es
geht also auf der service ist gut
gelaufen ich habe zwei drei dieser
finger verbrannt aber sonst ist alles
gut nach dem kochen die große reinigung
hygiene ist pflicht alexandra wird für
den abend dienst zurückkehren
[Musik]
afrika und seine gruppe arbeiten an
ihrem studenten business project ihrer
abschlussarbeit einen beratungsmandat
sie haben einen termin am hauptsitz der
kantonalen versicherung für die sie ein
firmen restaurant modell ausdrücken
sollen
wir haben hier einen saal für uns
reserviert
es ist cool hier zu arbeiten ihr wolltet
anfangs etwas komplett anderes machen
die beiden sachen passen überhaupt nicht
zusammen
wir haben noch viel zu erledigen wir
werden sehen ich muss nämlich in einer
dreiviertelstunde los viel arbeit und
immer persönliche projekte afri muss
alles in einklang bringen
das wirst du bist ob du dich beeilen
musste oder nicht werde ich mich beeilen
wenn ich letzter bin nie im leben
[Musik]
machen sie einen haufen mit der
bettwäsche schlüsselmoment des
housekeeping workshops für alex die
auswertung hat sich der junge mann in
ein perfektes zimmermädchen verwandelt
mein zimmerkollege und ich schauen jetzt
dass unser zimmer sauber bleibt
es motiviert mich die anderen ekelt mich
an ihr zimmer ist nicht sauber
ich frage mich wann diese auch putzen
weil verdammte scheint ihnen scheißegal
zu sein zimmer für zimmer entdeckt alex
das konzept des respekt in diesem fall
für das dienstpersonal zeigen sie mir
wie sie das machen
hier haben wir ein technisches problem
sie haben ja gar nicht gestoppt doch mit
dieser bürste
das macht man so und dann benutzen sie
für dich du schwende welches ist denn
für sie die wc bürste auf dem blatt
steht ja nichts von wc bürste steht
einfach bürste ich weiß genau wie man es
macht ich kenne das verfahren ich mache
einfach manchmal ein paar
flüchtigkeitsfehler
passen sie auf mit den bürsten für die
jene ist hier besonders wichtig beim
nächsten mal sollte es bei ihnen
klingeln
achtung nicht dieselbe bürste wie im wc
auch in der dusche benutzen
das sind jetzt drei fehler im badezimmer
die ich eintragen muss das sind fehler
die sie hätten vermeiden können
eine unaufmerksamkeit die nicht ohne
konsequenzen bleiben wird
ihr habt es bestimmt schon bemerkt heute
ist teamwork besonders wichtig so kommen
wir besser fördern
wir haben fünf minuten verloren ist doch
verständlich es ist schließlich ein
erster tag aber morgen wird es besser
sein ihr werdet euch gegenseitig helfen
ok genug gelacht jetzt machen wir diesen
kuchen
ich habe schmerzen seit ein paar tagen
ich werde zu einem spezialisten gehen
es geht schon aber wir machen viele
bewegungen mit dem arm das ist sehr
schmerzhaft
immer hatte eine schulteroperation
deswegen hat sich ihr eintritt in die
ehl bereits um ein semester verzögert
wie war beim ersten tag
sie sorgen dafür dass er verschiedene
aufgaben bekommen damit wir alle aspekte
kennen lernen
außer dass der eine junge und die ganze
arbeit weggenommen hat
[Musik]
ich versuche vier mal die woche hierher
zu kommen
aber es ist sehr kompliziert es gab zwei
abende an denen ich bis 8 oder 39 zu tun
hatte eine weitere herausforderung
pünktlich erscheinen auch nach einem
schönen abend unter freunden permanenter
druck
es ist sehr hart alles wird bestraft
wenn du einmal nicht erscheint gibt es
einen minuspunkt beim zweiten mal zwei
minuspunkte und beim dritten mal wird
die note annulliert man muss im august
wieder kommen und man muss 300 franken
für eine noch schwierigere nachprüfung
bezahlen
die versuche auf jeden fall das zu
vermeiden
das heißt nicht dass ich nicht ausgehe
aber ich bleibe schon eher auf dem
campus die studierenden im
vorbereitungsjahr sind verpflichtet ein
praktikum für das zweite semester zu
suchen
volles wochenprogramm unregelmäßige
zeitpläne wie geht das
die ehl organisierte einen großen
bewerbungs tag die karrieremesse da
wären viele leute sein und wird schlange
stehen müssen lebenslauf
motivationsschreiben und business class
abgeben damit man kontaktiert werden
kann
man soll aber auch deren hat man mir
gesagt viele vergessen dass ich fühle
mich nicht dazu bereit
alleine in meinem eigenen appartement
weit weg von meiner mutter zu legen
ich werde mich noch daran gewöhnen
müssen
[Musik]
der große tag der jobmesse 160
unternehmen bieten den studenten
praktika aller art und den diplomanten
jobs an
ich bin für ihren stand verantwortlich
und helfe ihnen bei allem was sie
brauchen
zögern sie nicht mich zu rufen annina
ist die ehl botschafterin für vier
unternehmen
ich versuche da zu sein für die
unternehmen für die ich verantwortlich
bin
um sicher zu gehen dass ihr auch
zurückkommen ich suche jetzt noch keine
fixe stelle für die zeit nach meinem
diplom
aber ich kenne viele leute die beiden
praktikum machen was eine gute
möglichkeit ist die unternehmen vor ort
kennenzulernen
alex hat sich schick angezogen um in
genf in einem großen hotel zu überzeugen
so könnte er in der nähe des familien
coupons bleiben entschuldigen sie stehen
sie ja wo ist denn das interkontinental
dass es dort hinten
das sind die jobs die hier angeboten
werden bankett room service am liebsten
würde ich an der rezeption arbeiten
ich bin super im kontakt mit leuten
vielleicht bin ich aber zu dynamisch für
diesen job
wir werden es sehen ich bin sowieso sehr
flexibel den job anbelangt ich habe
meine business card vergessen
im zimmer
ich gehe sie schnell holen bin gleich
zurück
immer geht auf die suche nach dem gral
einem gut bezahlten praktikum
hallo ich bin den vorbereitungs jahren
suche ein praktikum
ich wollte wissen ob sie freie plätze an
der rezeption haben wir haben unsere
rezeptions stelle schon vergeben aber
wir haben auch noch eine rezeption in
unseren sparen anstatt zimmer werden sie
behandlungen reserven
vielen dank schönen tag erster kontakt
mit dem harten gesetz der konkurrenz
dieser platz wird dutzenden von anderen
studenten angeboten
das wird sicher toll
jetzt kriege ich ein bisschen
lampenfieber so viele leute nicht nur
wir sondern auch die bachelor 3 die sind
zwar aus einem anderen grund hier aber
trotzdem viele viele leute eines ist
klar es gibt konkurrenz die bachelor
drei studenten im zweiten jahr
sie erhöhen die zahl der zukünftigen
praktikanten
[Musik]
und während dieser zeit tankt alexandra
sonne
ich musste eine schwere entscheidung
treffen eine unglaublich schwere seit
ich ein kleiner junge war spiele ich
volleyball
seit die vier oder fünf ich wollte schon
immer auf höchstem niveau spielen das
habe ich diesen sommer endlich geschafft
meinen vertrag unterschrieben
unglücklicherweise habe ich in der
ersten woche an dieser schule bemerkt
dass es nicht klappen wird jeden tag zu
trainieren
jede woche prüfungen am freitag ein team
verreist an turniere da würde ich zwei
tage kurse verpassen es gibt zwei punkte
noten abziehen musste mich entscheiden
meine zukunft ist hier an der schule
volleyball ist für mich eine
leidenschaft was unternimmt du mein
praktikum zu bekommen
meine taktik war an möglichst vielen
ständen vorbei gehen möglichst viele
spuren hinterlassen
und dann schauen wer sich für mich
interessiert und dann meine wahl treffen
dank meines vaters bin ich in einigen
hotels bekannt er hat mit den direktoren
gesprochen und die sind bereit mich zu
nehmen
das ist der einfachste lösung
ich werde jetzt die präsenz liste
ausfüllen um einen patch zu erhalten
dann werde ich noch meinen lebenslauf
ausdrucken und getarnt zu den
unternehmen bei afrim geht es mehr um zu
zwinkern und hände schütteln
er vernetzt sich um mandate zu finden
während er auf die verwirklichung seiner
eigenen projekte wartet ich stehe nicht
unter druck arbeit zu finden das ist ein
vorteil ich kann hier einfach gut leute
kennen lernen und mit ihnen plaudern
während annina und afri gelassen
scheinen sind die jüngsten unter druck
ein praktikum zu ergattern ist eine
verpflichtung sie sollten schnell
unterkommen
[Musik]
am wochenende fährt annina nach basel
ein moment der eisenbahn entspannung
nicht doch sie befüllt ich lerne gerade
französisch wir haben für die prüfung am
nächsten samstag
hier habe ich drei verschiedene stapel
der eine ist für die verben die ich zu
beherrschen glaube die gelten kann ich
teilweise teilweise kann
die roten sind die schwierigere das ist
mein lernsystem es ist wie eine ampel so
weiß ich grün heißt alles gut und die
anderen brauchen noch ein bisschen übung
abräumte
[Musik]
keine pause für immer die jeden sonntag
an einer tankstelle in lorch arbeitet
ich arbeite um geld zu sparen für meine
fahrprüfung und um ein praktikum in der
schweiz und einen teil meiner ausbildung
zu finanzieren
ich würde gern monatlich 1000 franken
beiseite legen um nach und nach meinen
eltern einen teil der studiengebühren
zurückzugeben
wie alle muss auch sie sich noch etwas
an diese tätigkeit gewöhnen aber und sie
lernen schnell
sie ist sehr dynamisch
[Musik]
annina merk das gemütliche rest der
familie unterstützt es ist doch den 68
minute zu sehen obwohl meine frau kann
uns geht es dir was wenn ein name klingt
einfach ist aber das ist doch ein
grundsätzlich super übrigen student
bestattet viele leute gesehen aber zum
multikultureller internationaler
ansonsten ist 14 offener sind hits wie
relax drittel weniger kariert alles
immer tiefer und das heißt eigentlich
ein brite
alaba dann innerhalb schoss sie wirklich
langweilig sich auch die nicht immer
sagt sie über den hof becker schaffte
sich aber immer sehr gern italien
hauptfeld und sie immer alles genau auf
solche parks kritisiert
ich habe mir ganz sicher sehr stark an
ninas mutter ist grossrätin und
präsidentin der basler
liberaldemokratischen partei auch an
ninas vater ist politisch tätig als
nationalrat und präsident der
erziehungsdirektorenkonferenz aber heute
abend ist es der traditionelle basler
stadtlauf von annina der die familie
mobilisiert
[Musik]
ja
st
[Applaus]
kommen
was ich immer schon sportlich es geht
nein nicht wirklich sie hat immer etwas
gemacht aber sagen wir ein großes sport
talent war sie in der schule weil sie
immer sehr gut dann weiß ich schon immer
ambitioniert und wollte gut sein
das ist wichtiger für sie oder kommt sie
[Musik]
alexandra beginnt denn konditorei kurs
so lala
ich bin heute um sechs uhr aufgestanden
ich muss meinen lebensrhythmus ändern
bist du bereit bist
ich finde die bäckerei interessant und
man lernt die sorgfalt wenn man einen
rechenfehler bei den zutaten macht
funktioniert das ganze nicht
und wenn man etwas zu lange bart
verbrennt man muss lernen auf jedes
detail zu achten
einerseits ist es toll wir können
während des backens immer wieder
probieren
andererseits nervt es mit der zeit aber
man muss es machen um alle berufszweige
kennenzulernen und zu verstehen wie das
geht
wie macht sich alex und naja manchmal
gibt es sich sogar mühe
nein er arbeitet sehr gut wenn er sich
auf seine arbeit konzentriert er lässt
sich aber schnell von seinen kollegen
ablenken und machten faxen mit ihnen die
kollegen machen faxen mit mir
[Musik]
wir sind voll
alex steht am ende des getränke kurses
es geht um seine note also billiger
rotwein aperitif dieses tief oder nichts
vorsicht falle
haben die einen auch keinen alkohol drin
alles ist nötig
so mühelos für emma die ihren dienst im
gourmetrestaurant der schule beendet wir
müssen noch die tischdecke für heute
abend auflegen und das war's schon jetzt
sind wir fast fertig von der mitte dort
beginnen
horizontal ich habe starke schmerzen
hier und in den fingern habe ich ein
beunruhigendes kribbeln nimmst du
schmerzmittel täglich etwa vier und in
der nacht auch noch kannst du sonst
nicht schlafen
nein ohne geht es nicht wenn ich mich so
bewege und den armhebel brennt es sofort
hat es ihnen gefallen ja sehr
was hätten sie besser machen können das
organisieren zwischen den verschiedenen
gesten zb war ich manchmal zu lange an
einem tisch während bei einem anderen
auf den wein gewartet wurde
also besser organisieren und prioritäten
setzen
einverstanden wenn an einem tischbein
und an einem anderen wasser serviert
wird wohin gehen sie zuerst dort wo wein
serviert wird da verdienen wir mehr geld
ja da man für den wein zahlt und für das
wasser nicht zweitens da der wein immer
vor dem essen serviert werden muss das
ist die priorität des sommeliers und
jedes mal wenn wein serviert wird müssen
sie genau aufschreiben von welcher
flasche wie viele gläser serviert worden
es ist ja schön und gut viele gläser zu
servieren
aber sie müssen sich immer notieren was
getrunken wird die viele deziliter von
welcher sorte wein
sie sind sehr dynamisch und sind gut im
kontakt mit kunden das mag ich was ist
eine französischsprachige equipe das
gefällt mir
behalten sie diese ausstrahlung für
heute abend sehr sehr gut einfach ein
bisschen organisierter
alexandra ist dran mit der bewertung
jedes detail zählt von der eignung bis
zur einstellung wie schätzen sie sich
ein
was denken sie wie sie sich verhalten
haben diese woche ich denke während der
schichten habe ich gute arbeit geleistet
jedoch habe ich mir selbst gewisse
pausen erlaubt die nicht hätten sein
müssen das team und das ist es was ich
ansprechen will
wenn sie hier sind arbeiten sie
grundsätzlich gut und effizient
das war super sie halten sich an die
anweisungen und den zeitplan
die arbeit die sie in der küche
geleistet haben war sehr gut
aber achtung ich habe ein bisschen das
gefühl dass ihnen der respekt fehlt
ihnen fehlt der respekt vor uns den
lehrpersonen aber auch gegenüber den
mitschülern zb gestern als wir
präsentationen hatten ihre präsentation
war gut da steht außer frage
aber während der präsentation der
anderen studenten haben sie mit ihren
kindern verhalten die zuschauer und die
präsentatoren gestört und abgelenkt sie
lachten und schwatzten während den
präsentationen der anderen das
tolerieren wir nicht wenn jemand spricht
wird aufmerksam zugehört das war
wirklich nicht
dazu kommt sie essen während der arbeit
sie haben ein dessert mitgehen lassen
das ist auch nicht in ordnung das
sollten sie wissen und anstatt es
zuzugeben als ich sie darauf ansprach
behaupteten sie es sei für eine
bakterielle analyse das ist einfach
frech und überhaupt nicht
professioneller dass du mir leid aber
wir sind alle auf der gleichen höhe
es ist kein oben und die anderen unten
wir sind alle gleich
das mit den absenzen ist auch noch ein
problem das zieht sie auch noch runter
immerhin sind sie heute gekommen
sie haben insgesamt nur einen minuspunkt
und nicht 2 es ist noch nicht alles
verloren
wenn sie in der nächsten woche alles
geben können sie vielleicht noch eine
note über vier hoffen
es ist viel arbeit und es geht schnell
also geben sie nicht auf
[Musik]
ran an die arbeit
ok also viel glück und bis später
was war das erste weißer rum dann hatte
ich whisky das nächste war wasser und
dann hatte ich irgendeinen likör
das war ein aperitif ziemlich sicher
aber so viel zählt das ja auch nicht
nein aber das sollte schon reichen
es war nicht sehr schwierig wir hatten
eine stunde zeit und waren nach 20 25
minuten fertig der es noch an der
prüfung wir sind in der gleichen gruppe
das ist praktisch denn so haben wir fast
den gleichen stundenplan und erweckt
mich am morgen weil man muss mich am
morgen wecken
wenn wir am vorabend raus sind es ist am
dienstagmorgen harte aufzustehen
[Musik]
wohin gehst du morgen
ich habe bei meinem chirurgin einen
termin wegen meiner schulter er wird mir
eine kortison spritze geben die sicher
zwei tage lang schmerzen wird dafür wird
es dann besser gehen
auch für ein paar prüfungen wird es
helfen wenn meine schulter schmerzfrei
ist
verlierst du punkte
ja das wird mich einen punkt kosten auch
wenn ich nicht den ganzen tag fehlen nur
eine lektion
ich verliere einen punkt das ist viel
was ist die erste vorspeise ein affe was
passt dazu wird es immer schaffen trotz
der schmerzen zu lächeln und die
geforderte reihenfolge in ihrer
bestellung einzuhalten
mit trüffel soße welcher wein passt dazu
[Musik]
an der schule ist das diktat der
kleiderordnung um 19 uhr 15 beendet der
moment für alexandra auf seine woche
zurück zu schauen
ich denke ich bin super service
ich bin in meinem element beim putzen
mache ich schnell mal ein paar witze
aber ich arbeite immer aber es scheint
sie zu stören mich ist das kein problem
in jedem beruf muss man lachen können
dann bleibt man professionell
meine arbeit ist gut niemand hat gesagt
dass ich störe die witze schaden nicht
ich verbreite nur gute stimmung
aber sie sehen das anders
[Musik]
zu der gänseleber empfehlen wir einen
riesling wenn sie weißen mögen für den
hauptgang empfehlen wir chardonnay immer
hat korrekt an den wein vor dem
hauptgang gedacht aber ein bisschen zu
früh in so einer situation ist es am
besten alle informationen zu notieren
und später zurück zu kommen damit sie
den aperitif noch genießen können sehen
sie sonst das ein bisschen viel
glücklicherweise hat sie rechtzeitig
ihre bestellzettel ausgefüllt kurz
gesagt ein beruf kann nicht in einer
woche erlernt werden
[Musik]
nächstes mal in der hotelfachschule der
letzte schultag für mich um viertel vor
acht werden die kunden kommen
wir halten unsere präsentationen und
wenn wir fertig sind verlassen wir das
zimmer dann rufen sie uns rein um uns
mitzuteilen ob wir bestanden haben oder
nicht die prüfungen haben bereits am
dienstag angefangen
ich hab noch dieses wochenende um mich
auf nächste woche vorzubereiten
fünf prüfungen an vier tagen es ist sehr
stressig
[Musik]
ich werde verhandelt habe ich das
praktikum bei meinem vater machen kann
ich werde einfach sagen ich habe in den
ferien dort gearbeitet und nicht wohl
gefühlt im team im reglement steht dass
praktiker im familienbetrieb nicht
erlaubt sind
sie haben die prüfung beendet
ja ich habe einiges verwechselt aber
egal achtung der rock ist ein wenig zu
kurz
es ist früher morgen in meinem kopf sage
ich mir ist aber noch drei wochen freue
mich auf die ferien das wird mir gut tun
was hast du heute abend vor
nach hause gehen oder trainieren oder
ausgehen
ich weiß es noch nicht mal schauen ob
ich fit bin und nicht so stark nach
fritteuse riechen
[Musik]